[Musique]
et c'est leur journal de l'afrique soyez
les bienvenus à la une ce soir au
sénégal la fin du procès dans la sphère
astou sorna le procureur a requis un an
de prison dont un mois ferme à
l'encontre de quatre sages femmes la
relaxe pour les deux autres elles sont
poursuivies pour non assistance à
personne en danger après la mort en
couche dans un hôpital régional d'astous
sorna le mois dernier
pour lutter contre les groupes armés
dans l'est du pays la république
démocratique du congo avaient instauré
l'état de siège il ya tout juste un an
nous ferons le bilan de ce régime
sécuritaire exceptionnel au nord kivu et
en ituri les civiles attendent toujours
les résultats
et puis à la fin de ce journal on vous
fera saliver devant les créations du
chocolatier andré bail à l'air il le
chef burkinabè au parcours atypique rêve
de développer la filière du cacao dans
son pays et il transmet aussi son savoir
à ses apprentis andré bayala était
l'invité du joint de l'afrique
au sénégal place aux délibérations dans
la sphère dit tu as tout sorna le procès
en première instance s'est achevée la
nuit dernière 6 h femmes sont poursuivis
pour non-assistance à personne en danger
après la mort le 1er avril dernier d'une
jeune femme d'une trentaine d'années
après des heures de souffrance un an de
prison dont un mois ferme a été requis à
l'encontre de quatre sages femmes la
relaxe pour deux autres l'afer a relancé
les débats sur la prise en charge des
femmes enceintes plus de détails avec
notre correspondant à dakar et les
mengao
il s'agit précisément dans cette affaire
de quatre sages femmes mises en cause et
placé sous mandat de dépôt et de deux
autres salles femmes qui sont
actuellement en liberté provisoire le
procureur a requis 11 ans de prison dont
un mois ferme pour les 4 500
actuellement sous mandat de dépôt et de
l'implication de l'amour das tournant à
serait beaucoup plus importante et la
relaxe pour les deux autres prévenus le
verdict est attendu le 10 mai prochain
cette affaire a dévoilé les
insuffisances dans les hôpitaux publics
sénégalais plusieurs manifestations ont
eu lieu une à louga et notre data
organisée par des associations de la
société civile dont le collectif
patients en danger il dénonce à la
mauvaise qualité de soins dans les
hôpitaux publics sénégalais le syndicat
a des médecins de son côté as évolué
solidaire aux sages femmes mises en
cause dans cette affaire de la mort d'
asseoir nabeul elle dénonce plutôt une
absence de politique à de l'état et un
plateau médical qui n'est pas encore aux
normes
le ministère de la santé de son côté a
effectué une enquête dont les résultats
incrimine le personnel soignant dans la
morde à ce soir là le ministre de la
santé dans une déclaration à la presse
avait affirmé que l'état travaille dans
le sens d'améliorer les conditions de
prise en charge des patients dans les
hôpitaux et je cite d'humaniser
l'accueil surtout au niveau du des
services d'urgence
il ya un an jour pour jour les provinces
du nord kivu et de l'ituri dans l'est de
la république démocratique du congo
était placé sous état de siège le
gouvernement entendait ainsi mettre fin
à l'insécurité qui règne dans cette
région depuis plusieurs décennies mais
douze mois plus tard cette mesure
exceptionnelle qui donne les pleins
pouvoirs aux militaires et à la police
est de plus en plus critiqué on fait le
point avec notre correspondant clément
bonnes roues
un an après l'instauration de l'état de
siège en ituri au nord kivu la promesse
du président félix tshisekedi de ramener
la paix dans la région est encore très
loin d'être réalisée sur la centaine de
groupes armés présents dans ces deux
provinces aucun n'a été complètement
démanteler les adf actifs autour de
baigner dans le sud de l'ituri a même
étendu leur zone d influence et le m23
que l'on pensait des faits depuis 2013
est de nouveau actif depuis novembre
selon les chiffres du baromètre
sécuritaire du kivu il ya aussi eu plus
de 2500 civils tués ces douze derniers
mois soit deux fois plus qu'au cours des
12 mois précédents les critiques se font
donc de plus en plus nombreuses écoutez
ces réactions recueillies à goma par
justin kalumba ils ont traqué quand même
et quelques officiers qui sauf acquise
et de collaborer avec le groupe armé que
ce soient les groupes armés étrangers ou
locaux en dépit de cela on doit noter
que l'insécurité continue à vent et à
des sièges et après tu as des sièges
c'est presque la même chose parce que
nous on voit le militaire venir ici nous
pensions que la sécurité sera très bien
que tout la vie va s'améliorer mais nous
sommes en train de voir qu'ils soient
s'empire du jour au lendemain tellement
que nous voyons les gens meurent tous
les jours il faut vraiment que des
solutions adéquates des solutions à la
hauteur de la menace soit prise et ces
solutions doivent être accompagnés par
et des mesures
d la diplomatie extérieure mais
également de la politique étrangère de
notre pays malgré les critiques
l'assemblée nationale a prorogé ce mardi
pour la 23e fois consécutive l'état de
siège et interroger sur notre antenne la
semaine dernière le premier ministre sa
malle ou condé refusé de voir dans cette
mesure un échec il affirmait toutefois
envisager je cite une requalification de
la zone concernée le président félix
tshisekedi a d'ailleurs annoncé la tenue
prochaine d'une table ronde pour décider
de l'avenir de ce régime exceptionnel
et dans le reste de l'actualité en bref
et en images le roi des belges philippe
se rendra en voyage officiel en rdc du 7
au 13 juin il s'agit de sa première
visite dans l'ancienne colonie belge
depuis le début de son règne en 2013
initialement prévue en juin 2000 dans ce
voyage a dû être reportée à plusieurs
reprises en raison notamment de la
pandémie de kobe 19 cette visite à
l'invitation du président félix
tshisekedi fera étape dont trois villes
congolaise kinshasa lubumbashi est servi
le premier tour des élections
législatives et des élections locales au
congo brazzaville aura lieu le 10
juillet première formation de la
majorité le pct du président denis
sassou n'guesso a déjà investi ses
candidats lupe ads et l'udf loups qui
ont annoncé qu'ils participeraient et
puis au burkina faso ou huit mineurs
sont toujours coincés depuis vingt jours
à plusieurs centaines de mètres dans une
galerie souterraine de la mine de perkoa
si pour qui il s'agit de six burkinabè
en faisant bien et un tanzanien le
gouvernement veut garder espoir mais dit
qu'il n'y a aucune garantie de les
retrouver vivants
elle est plus léger cette fois il fait
le bonheur des passionnés de chocolat à
ouagadougou fsa boutique dans le
quartier de la patte d'oie ne désemplit
pas surtout en période de fêtes le chef
andré maye elle a été l'invitée du
journal de l'afrique et il n'est pas
venu les mains vides et regarder
quand vous l'avez rectifier le chocolat
se déguste des gens le postulat langue
qu'on le laisse fondre avec la
température buccale et on le laisse
couler tout le long de la gorge et on la
compagne avait un grand bol d'air avant
de le relâcher pas les nerfs et là on a
tous ses arômes qui apparaît ce qu'on
est on n'avait jamais imaginé se
trouvait dans le chocolat pas alors
comment est née votre passion pour le
chocolat blanc alors il faut dit déjà
que moi je suis né dans un pays qui
aujourd'hui est le plus grand producteur
de cacao au monde et après ma formation
scolaire je me dis mais pourquoi ne pas
essayer d'apporter ma touche personnelle
parce que je suis issu d'une famille
d'un métier de bouche alors pourquoi ne
pas apporter une touche particulière au
lieu de la cuisine a quelque chose de
particulier
par exemple le chocolat et vous mélangez
le chocolat vos plats salés
pas vraiment ça mais j'apporte plus tôt
des créations de saveur au chocolat dit
chocolat de chez chef andré c'est vrai
que les chocolats en leur goût mais
quand vous avez affaire au chocolat de
chez chef andré là il est tout
particulier parce que nous utilisons des
épices de chez nous nous utilisons des
des arômes de chez nous nous utilisons
des céréales dessus de chez nous voilà
donc c'est ça qui fait la particularité
de notre chocolat alors être le seul
chocolatier du burkina faso et fournir
la présidence est ce que ça mais pas un
peu la pression
tout à fait je pense que je suis habitué
à travailler sous la pression et puis
d'ailleurs je pense que de nos jours il
faut faire les choses de façon
professionnelle on ne trouve pas le plus
le professionnalisme qu'on manquait de
l'autre côté je pense que la nouvelle
génération
de jeunes africains aujourd'hui
travaillent de façon à ce que le travail
soit remarqué alors justement vous allez
bientôt avoir de la concurrence parce
que vous formez aussi des apprentis est
ce que y en a qui veulent justement se
diriger vers cette filière du chocolat
en 2000 en 2007 j'ai été champion
d'afrique du chocolat et je dis
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une fierté
pour moi d'être le seul chocolatier et
je pense que la concurrence va apporter
beaucoup de choses et d'ailleurs je suis
en train de travailler dans le sens où
j'ai installé un centre de formation des
métiers de bouche qui va former dans la
sous-région des chocolatiers et même au
delà de la sous région
je vois par exemple le le rwanda qui se
signale déjà et nous allons former une
élite qui vont transformer la plupart du
chocolat et du cacao africain c'est
justement tout un paradoxe vous avez des
difficultés à vous approvisionner en
chocolat en cacao alors que l'essentiel
est produit en afrique parfois vous
devez même passer par l'europe oui il
faut dit déjà que dans ce sens le
président alassane ouattara déjà pris
des mesures qui vont beaucoup nous nous
aider et déjà il a dit en 2025 qui veut
que 95% du cacao africains soient
transformés et du cacao ivoirien se
transformer en côte d'ivoire et c'est
pour ça que déjà avec une coopérative
ivoirienne qu'on appelle sympa je
travaille déjà à les amener à
transformer le cacao humain et par les
nouveaux création que vous nous avez
apporté sur 22 alors je vous apporte est
une tablette qui
qui est qui à l'image de thomas sankara
qui est le père de la révolution de
notre pays qui a qui a donné une touche
spéciale à tout ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui en terme de création je
prends l'exemple du rwanda aujourd'hui
qui s'est appuyé sur les idées de ce
monsieur pour
transformer le pays et suscite à blaye
vous voyez par exemple je mets
produisant ce que nous consommons et
consommer ce que nous produisons écrit
google à cette tablette alors cette
tablette qu'elle a le goût sont bas là
ne sont pas là c'est une épice que qui
hacker qui est presque 20 le camembert
diva du camembert et qui est qui et qui
est qui qui lutte contre l'hypertension
et quand les gens consomment cette
tablette ils sont tout de suite voilà
une intention régularisées dont ce sont
des épices comme ça que j'utilise et en
dehors de ça aussi alors peut-être jean
françois cot pour vous dit voilà un
petit coucou de chef andré voilà une
tablette avec les épices de chez nous
alors moi je mange thomas sankara vous
mangez france 24 avec plaisir
et c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
merci de votre fidélité merci aux
équipes en régie et à l'édition je vous
retrouve lundi pour le journal de
l'afrique en attendant belle soirée sur
france 24
[Musique]
cette semaine le chanteur corneille est
notre invité dans le pari d or il nous
parlera de son nouvel album encre rose
sainte qui est inspiré par le bal des
zircons d'image on a tous à abandonner
normandeau notre vie de se séparer d'un
passé douloureux avec un mot ensemble
nous visiterons l'un des poumons de la
capitale le parc monceau et puis nous
irons découvrir l'oeuvre d'un tout jeune
artiste est là jean 6/2 je travaillais
vous que la dentelle dans cette série
est également le drapé cette dentelle
que vous voyez c'est une tente a été
faite par ma grand mère et qui a été
poursuivie après par malheur le pari des
arts du chanteur corneille a retrouvé
très vite sur france 24